-Guys, I'm here with the one
and only Michelle Obama.
We're about to surprise
some people on Zoom
who think they're in
a focus group
about a cooking show.
They have no idea
this is going to happen.
Are you ready, Michelle?
-Ready. [ Laughs ]
-There is this cooking column
that my sister --
-Michelle, thank you
for coming on the show.
I'm excited for our interview.
-What's happening right now?
-Is that Michelle Obama?
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Thank so much for having me.
Are these all your friends?
It's great to be here
with everyone.
-No, that --
-[ Laughing ]
-I thought these were
your friends.
I know --
-No.
-Are you kidding me right now?
Is this real?
-Are we -- It is real.
-Are we --
-It's real.
-Oh.
-No -- [ Laughing ]
-Yeah.
-We're in the wrong Zoom.
-Oh, my God!
-What happened?!
-So good for you, too,
You can see what it's like --
completely packed
with everything.
-Hello?
-[ Laughs ]
What?!
-Wow.
-Jimmy!
Wrong book!
-Oh, my God!
-Wrong book, Jimmy.
-What?
Oh, I think we're in
the wrong Zoom!
-Oh, my God.
No, you're in the right Zoom!
-Stay! [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Right.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, we would --
-Hey, it's Jimmy Fallon.
Wrong Zoom.
-Oh, hello.
-No way!
-[ Laughs ]
-You stop it!
-Hey, it's Michelle Obama!
Wrong Zoom!
-Oh, my God!
Was that for real?
-Yep.
-Yeah, that was real.
-It was real!
-[ Screams ]
-Oh, my God!
-That you should never use
a boxed cake, ever.
So if you use anything --
- Twinsy?
Twinsy?
-[ Laughs ]
-Twinsy?
Twinsy?
-Twinsies!
-[ Laughs ]
-Twinsy!
Oh, there you are!
-Ah, there you are, twinsy!
-Is this real?
Is this really real?
Oh, sorry. Jimmy --
-It's real. It's real.
-[ Gasps ]
-Oh, I'm sor--
-I don't believe it!
-Sorry, our bad.
-This is so amazing!
-That boxed cake
sounds good to me, by the way.
-[ Laughing ]
-Yeah, I love boxed cake.
-Let me make you a real cake.
[ Laughter ]
-What song should we do?
"Saints Go Marching In"?
[ Playing
"Saints Go Marching In" ]
-Ooh, yeah. Ooh, yeah.
Ooooooh, yeah.
-But before taking soda,
I went into diet,
and I love diet
more than I love the other.
So I'm with you, Jonie.
-[ Continues playing ]
We're diet sisters.
-Oh, my goodness!
♪♪
-What?!
-This isn't band practice.
-Wait, we're in
the wrong Zoom, I think.
[ Call line chimes ]
-Michelle Obama?!
-That was odd.
[ Laughter ]
-"That was odd."
-Cool, cool.
Anyone else?
-Wrong.
-Zoom.
-Oh!
-Wrong.
-Huh?!
-What?!
-Zoom.
-Wrong Zoom.
-What's happening?
-Is this happening?
-Oh, my God.
-[ Laughs ]
Hi, Michelle!
Hi, Jimmy!
-Gosh!
-We're in the wrong Zoom.
Sorry, guys.
-Our bad.
-Hi!
-My fault.
That's my fault.
-You can stay!
-Hello?!
Can you come back, please?
-[ Laughs ]
Wow, d--
-Oh!
[ Overlapping chatter ]
-Oh, my God!
-It wasn't an illusion!
-It really happened!
-Oh, my God.
-You guys are awesome.